when is uh when is the full full-length
body of work coming
early nature early next year early next
year like early Nation when is the Dolph
album dropping
I just saw the uh the artwork that that
the thing that dropped is the artwork
for the album right the picture or no
that's just for the single okay okay
okay yep yep yeah the dog the album is
on the way he's going away I can't give
you I can't you're on it maybe you
should be on it should be yeah shouldn't
maybe not was there um any sessions for
uh the uh part three of Dumb and Dumber
that were recorded like was that ever
something that you guys were gonna do
it's already done really
so there's a whole joint album already
done before he passed you guys already
had that [ __ ] wow
so that's going to come out too
um no Dumb and Dumber three no wow
well you just you just confirmed that so
confirmation alert no I did Dumb and
Dumber three coming soon no you give her
that
he did say you're not gonna be able to
do much without seeing my name next year
yeah
why not you know I don't think I ain't
gonna do no part three to nothing but
I'm just gonna spoil it right quick hmm
ain't no part threes
why not
a trio feels complete
yeah
but the way I do do [ __ ] is really one
and done but sometimes I'll be extra
right like
press a little harder and hit you with a
second one but
I think Point proven